Boa noite meus amigos minhas amigas para
mais uma live hoje eu não vou fazer
apresentação de artigos ou de novidades
científicas eu vou me resumir a
responder à suas dúvidas Ok então eu
peço para você que tá assistindo que
pegou a Live Não exatamente do começo
volte para ver se a sua pergunta já não
foi respondida em algum momento anterior
ok então eu já abi aqui o
documento a primeira pergunta do Carlos
ketman ah antes de responder só quero
esclarecer a vocês que eu tive
dengue Apesar de que a sorologia não deu
positivo mas ela foi cuida com 24 horas
de sintomatologia então é possível que a
sorologia IGM não deu positiva porque
não deu tempo mas os sintomas todos eram
consistentes com
d e hoje eu consegui
voltar trabalhar Apesar que ontem eu já
trabalhei um pouco mas não atendi
pacientes sal vivo mas foi um quadro
muito intenso tive muita mialgia muita
prostração alguma dor de cabeça não foi
o que mais me incomodou mas foi as
mialgias e a prostração e alteração
completa do hábito intestinal também uma
coisa que incomodou
muito fiquei também com exantema né com
vermelhão na
mas o que mais incomoda Sem dúvida é a
prostração muito bem a pergunta do
Carlos kman poderia falar sobre as
virtudes da
glicina eu falo sobre as virtudes da
glicina em vídeos tá que tem no
canal a glicina é aminoácido muito
interessante é aminoácido que faz parte
da glota né gluta Ela é composta de
glicina ácido glutâmico
e
cisteína Alé Além disso além de fazer
parte da glutona glicina é um aminoácido
calmante ajuda sim no sono tem um papel
sim de melhora da Resistência insulínica
melhora a sensibilidade a
insulina então é um mino arco muito
legal muito interessante e tem vídeos no
canal a respeito é só corar vídeos mais
antigos Quais são os melhores
procedimentos para evitar eliminar
oxidação de
LDL deixa eu dividir a tela
aqui
pronto deixar solo
aqui melhor coisa para você evitar
oxidação de LDL é de modo geral você ter
bons hábitos de
vida ter uma boa alimentação alimentação
sem ter
açúcares alimentos processados
[Música]
industrializados evitar excesso de
radicais livres até pelo uso de
substâncias de vegetais
orgânicos
e o o exac nicotinato de inositol
que é uma forma de vitamina B3 ele ajuda
a evitar a oxidação do LDL e aumenta o
HDL
também vários antioxidantes podem evitar
a oxidação de LDL como a vitamina E os
tocotrienois a própria vitamina C O Alf
libico os polifenois de modo geral né
os flavonoides e também
além dos flavonoides Nós temos também os
eh carotenoides que tem essa propriedade
de evitar oxidação do
LDL Tiago eu tenho acesso a dmso através
da clínica veterinária tanto líquido
quanto o gel na embalagem 99% de Pureza
porém também diz não aprovado para uso
humano no eBay encontro dmso
99,9 grau farmacêutico o senhor acha que
tem diferença pouca diferença viu mas
Tiago a não sei que você conheça
profundamente esse dmso eu só usaria o
de Graal farmacutico
99,9 Apesar que hoje eu acho que muitos
produtos veterinários são bem Seguros
sim mas aí eu começaria com o fabricante
primeiro antes de utilizar esse
produto Tiago para diagnóstico de pedra
na vesícula seria apenas ultrassom ou
teria algum exame de sangue que poderia
dar alguma indicação não aí realmente é
o ultrassom que vai indicar isso aí não
tem exame de sangue que vai confirmar se
a pessoa tem ou não tem pedra na
visita Quais são os melhores testes para
avaliar a saúde do fígado as enzimas
hepáticas Gama GT
TGO que é também conhecido como slt e
TGP também conhecido como
SGT as B rubinas também são
marcadores mas é mais de
obstrução o sistema canalicular do do
fígado mas sim a bobina serve também com
marcador de saúde de
fígado Então são esses exames TJ TGP ou
SGT
slt Gama GT e B rubinas são esses
marcadores
principais Estela Mares o uso do
suplemento de ribose seria um bom
substituto para diminuir a ingestão dos
carboidratos doos alimentos
Ah não a der ribose ser é um açúcar que
faz parte
né dos nucleotídeos e faz parte também
do att ele ajuda amentar a
energia para diminuir ingestão de
carboidratos eu usaria mais é L
Carnitina mas o os dois ajudam na
formação de energia Mas aí tem várias
substâncias especialmente as fibras que
vão ajudar a diminuir a compulsão
carboidratos Tá mas el carnitina ajuda
ã as próprias fibras ajudam tá ele
aumenta a insulina com passar do tempo a
derribos Que eu saiba não não ten essa
informação de que derribos aumenta a
insulina mas aumentar a insulina não
seria uma coisa boa aqui
vistela seria ruim
coelita o coliro de Eric carnosina é
indicado para tratar catarata no início
Sim era indicado para isso qual seria
uma boa marca a única marca que eu
conheço é o bright i 3 da Life extension
que é importado dos Estados Unidos no
Brasil teria
aí uma famácia de manipulação oftálmica
que faria isso mas eu não consegui
e que eles fizessem manipulado né no
caso tem essa esse boato que eles fariam
mas ao entrar em contato com eles eles
não tem esse produto então a única fonte
que eu conheço é o bright Eyes 3 da Life
extension Qual que é a dose ideal de
lisina para tratar herpes durante a
crise 500
mg três vezes ao dia para prevenir de
500 mg a 1 g por
dia Fernando castelani dor para
paralisia facial parcial apenas um lado
do rosto também conhecida como sí de Bel
de Bel Existe algum remédio suplemento
para acelerar a recuper ção além da
fisioterapia
Hum só você utilizar substâncias que
melhor o sistema
imune mas não é uma garantia que vai
acelerar a recuperação não né Você pode
tá utilizando zinco desculpa não glicina
zinco
Glutamina né
ã que mais próprio
própolis tem um que tá me fugindo aqui
agora mas é um derivado de parede de
alguns
fungos eu vou abrir aqui um documento
para poder falar exatamente qual que é
que me deu um branco agora
aqui
glucan tá tinha me esquecido mas é o
Beta glucano e a equin também tá eh o
extrato de Oliveira também é um produto
muito bom para sistema imune
antiviral e a timomodulina tá então são
todos esses são amo eh substâncias que
podem ajudar aí a melhorar o sistema
imune e acelerar a
recuperação R Elita Quais exames podem
ser feitos para avaliar a consistência
do sangue é o dímero o fibrinogênio tá e
provas de sangue comum aí o hemograma
completo tá fazer basicamente o dímero e
o fibrinogênio para ver se a pessoa está
com uma tendência a tromo você pode
pedir também os marcadores de trombose
trombofilia né proteína S proteína
C tem aí uma um painel que é só para ver
chance de
trombofilia
Eliane é possível a regressão de
ateromatose nos membros inferiores nas
carótidas é mas demora
muito Qual que é o suplemento que teria
mais
eficácia uma combinação natoquinase
picnogenol esses dois são bem
interessantes
juntos então também pode ser utilizado o
próprio nac a trimetilglicina
eh a a
l citrulina que é precursor da do óxido
nítrico também
ajuda o s7 que é um pul aí
de vegetais que pode ajudar também nesse
processo de ajudar aumento do óxido
nítrico e melhora da saúde das
artérias Eliseu eh a a Live da
quinta-feira vai ser sobre kinesiologia
médica tá vai ser esse o tema
kinesiologia
médica no caso suplemento a chagando o
ideal é ingerir por 90 dias manter no
intervalo de 30 dias de descanso ou pode
consumir para sempre o ideal é você
fazer o
intervalo mas eu não vejo problema
também de consumir
contínuo na lá Live passada perguntei se
comer mamão produz gordura no fígado e
você respondeu geralmente não porque
Mamão tem a fibra que segura a absorção
do açúcar no caso fazer suco de mamão
essa fibra destruída nesse caso o suco
de mamão produz gordura no fígado se com
demais
pode
eles leu acessei o site da fung house
daquele seu amigo vendedor de jba de
leão é não sou bem amigo dele nós somos
conhecidos tá e vi que tem o Smart drops
gotas E também o Smart Caps cápsulas
ambos produzem o mesmo efeito possuem as
mesmas substâncias são as mesmas
substâncias tá são extraídos também do
mesmo
cogumelo Smart drops tem absorção maior
que smart CS por ser eu creio que não é
só uma conveniência de ser líquido ou
sem
cápsula Smart Caps é absorvido em água
ou em
gordura absorvida em
Água suplementa fosfati diuc serina
absorvida em água ou em gordura em
Água soube que se eu ingeria o
suplemento espinheira santa 2 horas
depois de comer a absorção será muito
melhor do que se ingerisse logo depois
da
refeição caso em giro os suplementos
pinheira santa 2 horas depois de comer
porém junto com outros suplementos
absorção do espinheira santa será
prejudicada um pouco mas não é
significativo hoje eu estava pronto para
comprar o suplemento binol quando de
repente
fiquei sabendo da existência do kavak
10 dizem alguns que o kavak 10 é muito
melhor que o binol que possui
biodisponibilidade 10000% maior que é
oito vezes mais absorvido Isso é o que o
fabricante Alega tá não encontrei
nenhuma marca forte de suplemento n
Foods Life extension Health Origins V no
kavak 10 e também não encontrei nenhum
médico de alto nível falando sobre isso
no YouTube é não fiz vídeo sobre isso no
YouTube mas o o fabricante fala
exatamente essas informações que você tá
colocando
aí
eh as pessoas não fizeram vídeo sobre
isso porque seria uma propaganda do
produto tá o
Eliseu uma propaganda Direta do produto
isso no Brasil até o momento tem
restrições as pessoas podem ter
problemas com o conselho de medicina
para fazer propaganda de um produto
vendido
numa fassa de
manipulação 50 mg de cavac 10
equivalente a quantos miligram de
binol essa certeza eu não vou saber de
passar Eu geralmente passo nessa faixa
de 50 mg pensando que equivale a no
mínimo 200
mg Mas isso é uma quase com palpite
porque essa história da
biodisponibilidade quantas vezes é mais
absorvido isso daí co que a gente tem
certeza absoluta para um paciente você
receitaria o bikol ou kavac 10
Geralmente eu tenho prescrito kavac 10
eu tenho gostado do
resultado numa das últimas lives você
comentou que alguns suplementos
americanos de magnésio treonato TM
dosagem de 500 mg a 1 g reparei que a
dosagem do magnésio treonato da Life
extension e de algumas outras marcas é
menor do que
isso
Ah mas é mais ou menos essa nessa
dosagem sim se você for olhar vou até
Abrir o site da Live
extensionist lá vamos p
o deonato
ó magnésio
treonato ele aqui na minha frente
agora vou olhar aqui a
embalagem ó
magnésio em três cápsulas vão dar 2 1000
mg de magt que é o treonato então cada
cápsula vai ter aí um pouquinho mais de
mg
certo só que vai ter de magnésio na
forma
de
mineral 144 MG então talvez você não
tenha entendido o que eu falei eh os
comprimidos são mais de 500 mg e a dose
diária é mais de 2 g de magt é porque a
molécula desse aminoácido é muito grande
em relação ao magnésio então 2 g de magt
vão ter 144 MG de magnésio na forma do
minério
tá
puro depois você checa lá no site Mas é
isso que eu tô te falando
tá a dosagem não é menor do que essa vai
dar a dose diária de 2 g e equivale a 3K
o magnésio
treonato no YouTube você falou que
existem várias formas de azul de
metileno e para quem quer suplementar O
correto é o gral farmaceutico lógico
cund americano SP Quais marcas do
suplemento azul de metileno você
recomenda atualmente eu não recomendo
nenhuma só você manipular uma farmácia
de confiança porque na internet eu não
tô tendo essa segurança de recomendar
nenhuma não eu comprei uma vez há muito
tempo no Amazon mas o fornecedor parou
de
vender mas se você achar uma uma marca
USP Teoricamente daria para confiar
porque é grau
farmaceutico no caso suplemento Leite
anina você recomendou lá no YouTube a
dose de 200 mg a 400 mg por dia dividido
em duas tomadas não tô passando 1.00 por
dia a dose de 1000 por dia é boa sim se
não não chegou a dose máxima pode usar
essa dose de 1000 por dia mas eu
começaria com uma dose mais baixa para
não ter que prar necessariamente
desperdiçar
né dos Suplementos abaixo todos são
absorvidos em água ess tá com secado
para saber quem que absolve em água ou
ou em gordura ou Eliseu tá a maioria dos
Suplementos é em água mesmo tá não fica
preocupado com isso é só mais as
vitaminas lipossolúveis alguns
nutrientes como é o caso do alfal
lipoico que é em gordura Tá mas a grande
maioria em Água bom não fica
preocupadíssimo com isso
não soube de uma estratégia curiosa para
aumentar bastante a testosterona de
forma rápida eu apliquei a estratégia em
mim embora não tenha feito exame pelos
sintomas do meu corpo perceber que a
estratégia deu certo Qual a sua opinião
sobre essa estratégia a cada semana você
vai tomar um dos Suplementos da lista
abaixo em dose muito alta não pode tomar
por mais de uma semana em dose muito
alta porque o corpo se acostuma e o
suplemento pede o efeito
ASO de aspártico crisina feno grego long
jack Tribulus
maca eu não usaria nada em dose
altíssima não viu ô Eliseu você tá
fazendo isso de uma maneira um
pouco precipitada não dose para que dose
altíssima não tem sentido você vai usar
de suplemento não tem por tá vai correr
risco à toa não vale a pena
tá há 5 anos você disse no YouTube que a
dose de bacopa é de 250 450 mg por dia
na versão 40% de acosos Então até 750
por dia na versão de
20% da drct B tem 55 Qual é a dose faz
uma R de três só fazer a regra de três
né lembra como é que faz na
escola de 55% é feita por uma fá
manipulação qu a dose diária faça a
regra de três É verdade que o ideal que
a man seja consumida pela manhã para não
atrapalhar no sono já que ela aumenta na
culina algumas pessoas vão ter sim piora
do Sono usando bac
moniere à noite mas não é todo mundo que
tem esse problema ao dobrar a dose do
bacova moniere você aumenta apenas em
20% os
benefícios não sei de on Você tirou essa
informação Antônio Renato mulher vai
fazer dieta
cetogênica visando curar diabetes e
demais benefícios É verdade que carne
vermelha não é bom para mulher na dieta
cetogênica caso ela consuma excesso de
proteína o exercício
compensa não sei se eu entendi
isso carne vermelha não é bom paraa
mulher por
quê caso ela consuma excesso de proteína
o exercício
compensa Não entendi essa questão de
compensação você tá fazendo uma dieta
cetogênica ela é uma dieta que não pode
ter excesso de proteína porque os
aminoácidos podem ser convertidos em
glicose alguns aminoácidos são
glicogênicos Então se houver um excesso
um exagero de determinados
aminoácidos pode ser cometida em glicose
e a dieta não vai ser mais
cetogênica é essa que o cuidado que tem
que ser tomado agora a carne vermelha em
si não vejo como problema e eu não
entendi o que você quis dizer com
exercício compensa o excesso de proteína
dependendo da quantidade de proteína não
é não vai ser compensado
não beberina indicado por você dose
segura para mulher diabética dieta
cetogênica
eh beberina é 500 mg de duas a três
vezes ao dia essa aqui é a
dose eu não sei se tem alguém
acompanhando viu porque eu não estou
vendo ninguém se manifestando nos
comentários Mas qualquer forma deixa eu
avisar aqui no
grupo bem vamos pro
próximo Ah tá e níveis normais de
carnetina para homens e mulheres não tem
esse dado de quanto que é o normal no
sangue até porque a gente não pede esse
exame e não tá disponível nos
Laboratórios níveis de vitamina complexo
b normais para homens e mulheres que
estão fazendo dieta depende da vitamina
do Complexo B geralmente a gente mede
B12 e mede também a B9 tem muitas
vitaminas Complexo B que os planos de
saúde não
cobre agora não muda os níveis de
vitamina só para est fazendo cetogênica
não tá não sei por que você tá com essa
ideia na verdade cetogênica acaba
poupando as vitaminas do complexo B
porque elas são muito utilizadas para
queimar carboidrato e cetogênica vai
ajudar a preservar o complexo B no corpo
das
pessoas assisti uma live da D
citada por você para ensinar a usar o
aparelho medidor de copos cetônicos
recente ela falou que mulheres não devem
consumir carne vermelha na dieta
cetogênica já homens T mais tolerância É
tem que saber de onde ela tirou essa
informação o ideal é que a mulher medir
a carnitina e experimentar eu não
conheço laboratório que meça a carnitina
pode ter mas vai ser um laboratório de
exceção em Plant saúde não cobre isso
ela também falou que não é bom ficar
muito tempo em cetose depois pode trazer
prejuízos e bom apenas tratar os
problemas de saúde e sair por um
tempo sim a maioria das pessoas que faz
cetogênica faz alternado faz um tempo
cetogênico depois sai da cetogênica
agora para quem tem Alzheimer eu não
recomendo sair da cetogênica mas não é
uma cetogênica acentuadíssimas né é uma
cetose
leve que entra em cetose hoje amanhã
Pode não estar em
cetose sim lógico depende da do tanto de
jejum que fez da atividade física qual o
melhor horário para medir cetose de
manhã Eh de manhã também mas a a não tá
errado medir à noite
não Sim Isso é verdade a doutora falou
que na manhã os hormônios estão muito
altos segundo ela melhor horar é à noite
é faz sentido porque tem muita gente que
não entra em cetose de manhã com
facilidade tá esse é um problema mesmo
confirmo isso Quais exames uma mulher
diabética pode fazer deve fazer saber se
não tem deficiência
nutricional tem que fazer os exames
normais vitamina B9 B12 se puder fazer
B2 B6 também é ótimo né não é diferente
de uma pessoa normal
não
você disse que para entrar em cetose
pode levar de TRS dias a 3 meses isso
ocorre basicamente por quê porque cada
pessoa tem o limar para virar a chave
metabólica de começar a queimar copos
cetônicos É por isso antô Renato uma
questão de flexibilidade
metabólica E também o tanto que essa
pessoa tá ou não tá distúrbio né de
queima de se for uma pessoa que tá com
muita resistência insulínica pode
demorar mais para fazer essa essa girada
metabólica a cetoacidose é quando a
Glicemia está muito
alta a cetoacidose diabética é quando o
organismo tá muito descompensado e não
consegue mais metabolizar eh
adequadamente a glicose aí o corpo acaba
produzindo excesso de copos
cônicos Renata Doutor 30 anos acabei de
descobrir um nódulo na tireoide de 6,7
por 5,5 no lobo direito tem com a
textura heterogênea por ser coico sólido
chama Zoom tirades 4 meu estrogênio está
baixo demais e cabelo está caindo mais
de 1
ano
D C resto dos exes normais o ser pequeno
talvez não queiram fazer função Dev
preocupar com
cân nódulo t r 4 6 cm tão pequeno assim
né 6 mm tão pequena
assim PR eu par por câncer deve porque é
um p 4 mas eu não ficaria desesperada
não
Como acabar com o nódulo de forma
natural use iodo com selenia uma
combinação de iodo com celen vai ajudar
você a se livrar desse nódulo aí mas
pode demorar mais de 2 anos e fique
tranquila tá não fique
desesperada maioria desses nódulos de
Ráo 4 não é
nada Antônio marca de beberina que você
usa eu uso manipulado mas tem umas
marcas boas tem chama-se integrative
therapeutics americana integrative
therapeutics falar no inglês um
pouquinho
melhor uma marca muito boa para
berberina a marca americana mas eu faço
geralmente uso manipulado
contraindicações para mulher diabética
de 53 anos e dose segura dose já
comentei beina de 500 mg duas a três
vezes ao dia é uma do bem
segura contraindicação para diabético
geralmente não tem pelo contrário para
isso
né Existe diferença entre dieta
cetogênica nutricional e
terapêutica a diferença seria
basicamente a intensidade da dieta para
você atingir os seus objetivos né a
terapêutica seria mais
intensa a cetose né então Digamos que
uma dieta cetogênica nutricional você
poderia estar satisfeito com 0,5 de Bet
hidróxido butirato no sangue e a
terapeutica no mínimo um de Bet hidroxid
butirato de entre um a qu seria
basicamente essa a
diferença isso no aparelinho que for o
dedo tá o metr
tiado vitamina A de 5000 vitamina D de
1000 vitamina K2 de 100 é uma boa dose
segura para o homem jovem de 1 76 56 kg
tammin de
36 não é uma dose que
seja você colocou 4.000 ou 40.000 você
deve ter errado na hora de digitar né eu
não faria
40.000 se isso aqui é uma dose diária tá
Faria 4.000 de vitamina D com 100 microg
de K2 a a 5000 é não tá uma dose muito
exagerada não tá só que você errou um
zero aqui colocou um zero a mais depois
40.000 mas acredito que tenha sido um
erro
digitação
eu devo estar com algum problema aqui
porque não tá aparecendo comentário para
mim de ninguém né e o Eliseu disse que
tá acompanhando ao vivo mas não tá
aparecendo comentário nenhum para mim
seu Eliseu se você tiver vendo
viu pode ter dado um bug porque eu tô
tentando reaproveitar a Live da semana
[Música]
passada Antônio Renato
picnogenol e diabetes ajuda sim pinol
ajuda é um bom suplemento para diabético
dos segura sem a 200 mg por dia mas eu
pode usar até mais até uns 400 mg por
dia Nilsa pode falar protocolo para
dengue ou chicungunha em uma live tira
dúvidas você diz que é o mesmo da doença
de 2020 mas não achei na lista é porque
eu não coloquei mas
é não posso
falar mesmo Live fechada não posso falar
pessoal mas é Ivete e Anita tá bom Ivete
Anita eu mesmo usei agora essa semana
passada eu usei Ivete qu imprimidos por
dia tomei durante 7 dias ok
aan
que é
o
Anita tem uma dose um pouquinho
diferente mas eu não vou falar aqui para
não atrapalhar não dá problema na no
canal tá mas você consegue achar isso
facilmente aí na
internet Jurandir hoje muitos médicos e
outros profissionais de saúde utiliz o
microscópio deic escuro é verdade para
ver a formatação do sangue fala muito do
o sangue sujo Qual a melhor forma de
fazer limpeza do
sangue então Jurandi eu não uso a
técnica do microscopia escuro do campo
escuro tá eu tenho um pouco de reserva
quanto a
isso eu acho que esse tema é um tema
muito grosseiro muito leivo sangue sujo
né então eu não faço uso desse termo e
nem muito menos de protocolo de limpeza
de
sangue Eduardo Henrique Quais são os
suplementos que podemos usar para
aumentar a
dopamina a el tizina é um
aminoácido que é transformado em
dopamina que também pode ser
transformado depois em outros
neurotransmissores como noradrenalina e
adrenalina tá então a el tirosina
seria
o o suplemento indicado para aumentar
dopamina outra coisa que ajuda também
que é muito usado para Parkinson
é a mukuna
prens mun pruri também aumenta a
dopamina então el tirosina e mun
pruri Tiago se o problema maior foi a
modificação genética do glúten Qual a
diferença entre o glut
ancestral m etc e o glúten não
geneticamente ficado A diferença é que o
o trigo na verdade quer dizer o trigo
ancestral tem uma quantidade
infinitamente menor de glúten o fato de
não ser gmo já não seria considerado
ancestral não gmo é um outro conceito
ancestral é
um vegetal que não sofreu manipulação
pelo ser humano essa que é conceito
então tem vegetais que não são gmo e que
também não são ancestrais
gmo um vegetal gmo não pode ser
ancestral mas existe vegetal que não é
gmo e também não é
ancestral farinhas como eic corne Emer P
Cut são mais caras e mais difícil de
encontrar mas se eu comprar Marinha de
trigo orgânica não transgênica não seria
a mesma coisa não não seria a mesma
coisa confunda orgânico com ancestral
orgânico que não tem
uso de
agrotóxicos defensivos agrícolas tá
ancestral é uma espécie não manipulada
pelo homem com melhoramento genético
melhoramento genético não é a mesma
coisa que gmo gmo é uma manipulação
genética direta e enquanto que a gente
tá falando de não ancestral eh São não
passaram necessariamente por manipulação
genética direta mas que foram feito
seleção selecionamento genético ao longo
de séculos aí
não sei se você consigue entender a
diferença mas não é a mesma coisa
não qual que é a marca de beberina Já
respondi Juliana zbl indicada Não ele tá
repetindo a mesma
pergunta
eh pra maioria das pessoas
ou já respondi mas deixa complementar
não precisa ficar cetose muito tempo mas
pro
diabético e pro paciente que tem
Alzheimer eu manteria a dieta cetogênica
indefinidamente A não ser que essa
pessoa consiga uma reversão completa da
Resistência insulínica depois de mes
cetogênica e conseguir ficar sem essa
resistência insulínica com a dieta low
carb
tá quais são experimentações exames de
casos para dieta cetogênica já foi
falado já tá
repetindo também
repetindo Eu fiz um vídeo Há 5 meses
dizendo que não é bom ingerir cafeína à
noite para não atrapalhar o sono Cacau
contém cafeína certo sim cont temm um
pouco de cafeína também é ruim gerir
Cacau à
noite depende da sensibilidade da pessoa
se lá for sensível é ruim né
chocolate Cacau 100% orgânico contém
cafeína e também atrapalha o sono se for
consumido à noite depende da
sensibilidade da pessoa se ela for
sensível atrapalha sim tem que fazer um
teste tem pessoas que são
metabolizadores rápidos e
metabolizadores
lentos após o almoço se a pessoa quiser
tomar algum suplemento em jejum ela
deverá esperar quantas horas sem
comer no mínimo no mínimo Eliseu Sea
quiser ter certeza em jejum são 3 horas
tá depois de comer e já comido uma uma
refeição muito pesada até mais mas
digamos 3 horas
aí encontrei um suplemento de magnésio
dronato é que comentei agora Dev ser da
L extension né você vê que da lá esente
a porção são três não são é são três
cápsulas que dão 2 g agora esse que você
falou
aqui 2 g em quatro cápsulas treonina 157
magnésio 260 a consumir oito cápsulas
por dia a pessoa irá ingerir 520 MG de
magnésio 315 de
treonina Tá esquisito essa proporção
aqui viu Eliseu porque era para ter
muito mais trulin do que magnésio não ao
contrário senão não faria sentido essa
essa molécula da treonina é muito maior
que do magnésio como é que tem mais
miligram de magnésio que de treonina
algo tá errado aí
nessa
composição encontrei um suplemento com a
seguinte composição cada uma dose dois
cápsulas contém epimed long jack jinzen
tfil todas as substâncias mencionadas
encontradas na natureza não t lafila é
uma droga não é encontrada na natureza
esse suplemento é seguro não sei
Teoricamente não deveria ser vendido sem
receita por ter Tad fila na composição
então pode ser bem suspeito esse
suplemento aí eu não
compraria bem deixa eu
abrir do
YouTube
para ver se eu consigo ver comentários
ao vivo porque dentro do stream ard eu
não consigo
ver vou ter que entrar aqui no
YouTube v a Live ao
vivo não não é esse
aqui é esse
aqui e ver se aqui agora consigo ver os
comentários então eu tô tendo que ver
pelo próprio YouTube Boa noite
satisfação com seu retorno Dr al
obrigado Carlos eild boa noite boa noite
enil boa noite Denise Engraçado que não
apareceu nenhum comentário de vocês no
stream ard Boa noite Manuel
Ferraz Boa noite
Fernanda Boa noite Miriam
Eliseu quando você falou de magnésio
treonato tal tal
tal quando você falou magnésio treonato
na dosagem de 500 mg a 1 g você se
referiu ao magnésio elementar não tava
tava falando na molécula inteira o
tamanho da cápsula F menzes Doutora usar
repelente de farmácia tóxico o de
caridina não é não tem algum repelente
natural tem vários eu falo isso no vi
do
do do deng
né Tá falhando a minha internet não sei
boa noite Eliane miram o nq é um bom
suplemento para cálculo renal sim é
interessante
miram é interessante eu já usei bem
interessante Dr Alan Você conhece o
suplemento uplift da da Essential
conheço que é a base de cafeína óleo de
cártamo camando cafeína em cápsulas
assim pode ser nocio pode tomar muito
cuidado com excesso de
cafeína tomar água com limão e jejum Ao
acordar é a mesma coisa que tomar água
com limão 3 horas depois de comer uma
[Música]
refeição Não não é exatamente a mesma
coisa
não
Eh boa noite Estela Mares Eliseu é
recomendável não comer alimentos ricos
em carboidratos not turno da manhã sim é
recomendado você evitar carboidrato de
manhã para evitar pico glicêmico é
melhor você comer de manhã mais proteína
e e gordura
saudável
bem pessoal quase 1 hora de Live e agora
só agora que eu tô começando a ver os
comentários ao vivo tá o streamyard
simplesmente não tá me apresentando
algum algum bug aí pelo fato da Live ter
sido criada há muito tempo provavelmente
foi
isso mas bem eu vou encerrar por agora
espero que eu tenha respondido a dúvida
de
vocês quando a pessoa come com cortisol
alto a comida engorda mais do que se o
cortisol estiver baixo sim cortisol ele
aumenta a Glicemia do do do aumentar
quade de açúcar no
sangue Álvaro comprei eh manteiga de
karitê mais e caridina para ser
repelente só que ele tirou a mensagem
não sei
por bem pessoal eu vou vou encerrar por
agora tá estamos quase uma hora aí de
Live peço desculpa para vocês se eu
demorei para interagir
porque realmente eu não tava vendo as
mensagens eu achei que não tinha ninguém
acompanhando suplemento coentro em gotas
possui os mesmos benefícios do alimento
coentro
sim tem os mesmos
benefícios obrigado a vocês ter
acompanhado ao vivo pela paciência de
vocês pela doença agradeço de coração a
vocês aí e revejam vídeo e se as
perguntas eu respondi da lista se tiver
alguma que não ficou Claro depois por
favor não deixem de me contactar
para esclarecer aí qualquer fato aí que
seja necessário tá bom Um abraço grande
para vocês até a
próxima